a big day 75 years in the making a local  98 year old world war ii veteran finally  getting the recognition that he deserves  private first class inofrio zakari they  call him no no he was awarded a purple  heart at las vegas city council this  morning he took part in the d-day  invasion at omaha beach and he was  wounded during the battle but in the  chaos his wounds were never documented  today he was honored for his heroism  no no it's wonderful to have you here  today you truly epitomize  all the best of the greatest generation  and we are so grateful for your service  and to have you  a part of our community i'm just  overwhelmed  with everybody here  and i wishes all  good luck and god bless you  just incredible isn't it zakari also  named citizen of the month